Speaker 1: We are starting to see a softening
in the pandemic recovery.
And, yeah, some of it has to do with a..
Taxers, what has been a fantastic, you know,
80, 85, even 90 percent recovery from the
pandemic.
And I mean, economically and I also mean from
a public health standpoint is now slowing
down.
Now, you might be saying.
Well, David, wait a second, are you criticizing
the state of play in the United States during
a Democratic administration?
I thought you were a Democratic shill or a
shill, as someone recently called me.
No, you guys know, many of you know, I've
never been a Democrat.
I don't really care about the Democratic Party.
I just call things the way they are.
And we are now seeing jobless claims up and
higher than expected.
Initial jobless claims for the week ending
July 3rd came in at three hundred seventy
three thousand new jobless claims.
That's higher than the three hundred and fifty
thousand that was expected.
Initial unemployment claims had been on the
decline.
Big picture for months now, but we're now
seeing a reversal.
Jobless claims going up.
Meanwhile, there are broader concerns about
the global economic comeback.
Anecdotally, Japan has now declared a state
of emergency in Tokyo and covid cases are
surging globally.
They're surging in a number of countries and
overall and they're also up a bit, actually
close to 20 percent in the United States.
Check out these numbers around the world.
Cases had bottomed out in mid-June at about
three hundred and sixty thousand a day.
Globally, cases are now up 12 percent just
in the last few weeks to over 400000 cases
a day.
This is believed to be mostly because of the
more contagious Delta variant.
These you know, sometimes people see something
on the news, more contagious Delta variant.
That doesn't really mean anything.
No, we are seeing because it spreads more
easily, 12 percent more cases globally per
day.
There's now an even more contagious LAMDA
variant.
We don't yet know much about it, which could
be the next to spread and become dominant.
So cases up 12 percent globally in the United
States, cases are up 20 percent.
We had gotten down to about 12000 cases a
day.
In the US.
We are now up to more than 14000 cases a day
in the U.S.
That is a big jump.
Now, so far, fortunately, we are not seeing
higher deaths.
But remember that deaths lag cases by weeks.
The hope would be the optimistic scenario
is even though we're seeing more cases because
Delta's more contagious, if you're vaccinated,
you still are unlikely to get hospitalized.
If you get the virus and you're unlikely to
die if you get the virus if you are vaccinated.
That's the hope.
We don't really know that yet.
We need another three to four weeks to see
if that's the case.
And meanwhile, 20 percent of Americans still
don't want the vaccine if you care about public
health.
You would go and you would get the vaccine,
if you care about the economy, you would go
and you would get the vaccine.
If you care about avoiding another sort of
shutdown to some degree in the fall, you would
go and you get the vaccine.
What are we doing here?
Let's put up this pathetic chart of U.S. vaccinations
per day and you will see if you were watching
today that we are basically down to the level
of daily vaccination that we saw in January.
Now, think back to that, OK?
In January, we had almost no vaccines.
It was health care workers.
And I think we were starting to make the vaccine
available to the oldest and most vulnerable.
We are vaccinating the same amount of people
now.
When we have full availability, you just walk
in in many places.
You don't even need an appointment.
You just get vaccinated.
And somehow we are vaccinating no more people
over the last week than we were doing in mid-January
when availability was close to not not literally
zero, but it was very, very low.
And in other countries, people are just sitting
there waiting for the privilege of having
the vaccine access that we have.
And we are seeing it reflected not just in
the case numbers, but in the economic uncertainty
as well.
And so my appeal is, if you don't care about
other people, if you don't care, but if you
just don't want to get vaccinated because
you have assessed that you were at low risk,
either accurately or not, and you don't really
care about other people or whatever else,
do you care about the economy because the
economy is wrapped up in the success of the
public health recovery?
Come on, guys.
The world is desperate for the vaccines that
we have an overflow of.
Just go and get vaccinated.
Let me know your thoughts on this.
Do you think that this will continue to worsen
or is this a temporary blip as we hopefully
get closer and closer to herd immunity?
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we will see.
I mean, listen, but 10 days from now, we'll
have the answer.
And hopefully it is a positive one and not
a negative one.
Remember, The David Pakman Show does depend
on the support of people in our audience to
fund the program and to do the things that
we do, the primary source of that funding
is membership.
You can sign up at join Pakman Dotcom.
We do an extra show every single day for people
who are members.
It's quite a show, I will tell you that.
And you can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one if you would like a discount.
I say just give everybody the discount.
Who cares?
Get people involved.
You can sign up at join Pakman Dotcom and
enjoy the bonus show almost instantly.
And yesterday's was a doozy, let me put it
that way.